SPEAKER 1: Flutter Live is
happening on December 4.
Tune in to g.co/flutterlive for
exciting news and demos from
the Flutter team, as well as
exclusive behind-the-scenes
content through the eyes of your
on-the-ground correspondent,
me, Martin Aginnis.
SPEAKER 2: And
me, Emily Fortuna.
Before or during the
event, tweet your questions
and comments with the
hashtag #AskFlutter.
We also invite you to
share your own story
about how you splutter,
by recording a video
and tweeting with the
hashtag #MyFlutterStory.
Top tweets will be
displayed in the venue
and answered on the livestream.
SPEAKER 1: We look forward
to hearing your stories,
questions, and experiences.
Sign up to watch the pre-show
and keynote livestream
at g.co/flutterlive.
[MUSIC PLAYING]